I for the billionth time on this show  and we counter-puncher I react the  opportunities in front of me at that  moment I'm not predicting here I'm  telling you the past the past will tell  you the future it's always the same game  I would tell you if I'm a photographer  right now the number one place I would  build an audience on this number want  this snapchat I predict in 2016 that  snapchat will have a number one two or  three spot in the most important apps in  the world twitter has a fire hose  problem twitter has gotten nosy twitter  is noisy as hell twitter struggling  people don't understand it it's losing  attention  Nintendo why cuz they're [ __ ] up like  there's no fifteen-year-old like the  fact that Nintendo is not winning in-app  gaming is ludicrous  I am predicting that facebook acquires  Instagram visit dot ly is the emerging  social network with junior high kids in  America and China it has a chance